agathe
non
[Musique]
je fais souvent le même rêve je sens le
soleil chauffe et ma peau et des brames
série tendrement j'ai envie de rester là
pour toujours et c'est impossible
j'ai une hypersensibilité à la lumière
du soleil
les rendez vous chez le médecin font
partie de mon quotidien il n'y aura
jamais de rémission et chaque année qui
passe augmente le risque alors je reste
tout le temps à l'intérieur derrière des
fenêtres adapté je dors le jour je vis
la nuit et je fais de la musique et que
j'en ai l'occasion
oui c'est à lui qu'est ce que j'aurais
dû dire salut je m'appelle katie price a
fait dix ans que je t'observe depuis ma
fenêtre je suis amoureuse de toi et je
te laisse qu'un en permanence c'est le
truc de taylor swift elle a des
histoires compliquées et elle en fait
des chansons géniales
je comprends pas qu'on soit jamais
croisés je passais devant chez toi tous
les jours on attend m'entraîner ça te
dirait qu'on fasse un truc un de ces
quatre je suis très occupé la journée
mais je suis libre le soir qu'est-ce que
tu price envie de faire il ya tellement
de choses que je fais ce que tu
m'emmènes à ton premier concert
[Applaudissements]
c'est riou auxerre des meilleurs moments
[Musique]
tu vires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça m'ennuie beaucoup qu'ils soient pas
au courant j'ai prévu tout lui dire mais
là je suis quelqu'un va juste une
maladie et j'ai besoin de séduire encore
c'est pas quelque chose que tu pouvais
me cacher je suis déçu mais on n'est pas
un couple qui baisse les bras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un
ge a pas mieux
[Musique]
j'ai attendu toute ma vie de ressortir
ça